[Musique]
alors depuis lundi le port du masque est
devenu obligatoire dans les lieux
publics clos des manades des masques
indispensable donc mais qui
représenterait coût de plus de 200 euros
par mois pour une famille de quatre
personnes
certes vous venez d'annoncer la
distribution de masques gratuits aux
plus précaires et aux personnes à risque
mais comment s'organisera cette
sélection par quel organisme
au bout de combien de temps et pour les
autres quand vous aujourd'hui l'urgence
est un la gratuité comme vous le
proposez des gens juin une résolution
des groupes des députés du groupe gdr la
gratuité un coup oui d'ailleurs
supporter largement par les
collectivités
merret coût moindre qu'une surcharge des
soins en réanimation et n'en déplaise
aux propos ici ou sénat ya quelques
temps de la ministre pas nier une hache
et la gratuité n'est pas je cite un
frein à l'innovation un frein le frein
en fait c'est la perte de nos outils de
production comme par exemple ouzzine de
masques à plaintel dans mon département
fermé depuis deux ans un projet pérenne
d'une coopérative d'intérêt collectif
est menée à grasse toujours en côtes
d'armor avec l'appui de la région et du
département
voilà un levier pour assurer notre
sécurité sanitaire de proximité
pourvoyeuse d'emplois en plus
le soutiendrez vous bref monsieur le
ministre porterez-vous enfin le choix
politique de la gratuité des masques
pour tous au bénéfice de la cause de
lags de la société de nos concitoyens
notre pays en a les moyens
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes des solidarités de la santé
monsieur vers on avait la parole madame
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice pruneaux il me
revient l'immense honneur de répondre à
votre dernière intervention si j'ai bien
compris
au cours de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement j'ai répondu à une question
similaire hier à l'assemblée nationale
et le président la république a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer hier dans une
interview télévisée pour dire qu' il n'y
aurait pas de distribution gratuite pour
tous de masques et quand aucun pays
d'ailleurs de le faire aucun pays au
monde en aucune circonstance et qu'en
revanche il y avait une distribution qui
avait eu lieu déjà très tôt à
destination des publics fragiles des
personnes les plus précaires dès le
début alors que nous étions en train de
constituer des stocks nous assurions la
distribution à travers les associations
à travers les mairies à travers les ccas
de 5 millions de masques par semaine de
manière à protéger les personnes les
plus fragiles j'ai déjà également
annoncé hier que pour 2 millions de
français en situation de vulnérabilité
sanitaire cette fois sur prescription
des masques chirurgicaux pourraient être
remboursés et pris en charge totalement
par l'assurance maladie donc nous
portons évidemment une attention plus
fragiles madame la sénatrice
j'aime aussi comme vous les
mathématiques et j'entends et je lis ça
et là qu'il y aurait un coût pour une
famille de deux enfants de 220 euros par
mois j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que j'ai à coeur de porter des
masques qui ne sont pas des masques
chirurgicaux que je réserve aux
soignants mais des masques qui sont à la
fois lavables renouvelables et qui sans
doute pollue moins et même certainement
pollue moins que les masques destinés
aux soignants se masquer la coûte 1 euro
il est lavable et réutilisable jusqu'à
30 fois admettons vous utilisiez trois
masques par jour et que vous ayez besoin
30 jours de porter un masque et vous que
vous êtes 4 j'arrive un calcul qui est
plus proche des 15 euros 20 euros à la
rigueur si on inclut week-end que des
220 euros
cela étant s'annonce à notre pas sa note
pas madame la sénatrice la priorité que
vous portez au fait que les plus
fragiles puissent être protégés et qui
n'est pas d'obstacle financier
croyez moi comme ministre de la sorte de
là
santé mais aussi des solidarités je
ferai personnellement à ce que personne
ne soit en impossibilité de porter un
masque
compte tenu d'un obstacle financier je
crois que c'est essentiel et nous
pourrons nous retrouver autour de cet
objectif
merci la parole la parole et à notre
collègue andré vallini pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères une
tragédie se déroule sous les yeux du
monde entier en chine
arrestations massives et arbitraires
camps d'internement et de rééducation
viols et tortures stérilisation forcée
et avortement contraint la chine
martyrise le peuple ouïghour et peut
mener jusqu'à sa disparition
face à ce qui s'apparente déjà comme un
crime contre l'humanité une mobilisation
internationale s'esquisse avec notamment
les états unis de donald trump qui a
annoncé des sanctions alors face à cette
tragédie
que dit la france et surtout que fait la
france
pour vous répondre la parole et à jean
yves le drian ministre de l'europe des
affaires étrangères de la parole
monsieur le sénateur vallini c'est une
question grave sur laquelle je me suis
déjà exprimé hier est effectivement
l'ensemble des témoignages des documents
relayées par la presse des documents
fournis par les organisations de défense
des droits de l'homme
l'ensemble de ces témoignages sur la
situation au xinjiang fait état de
pratiques injustifiable qui ne peuvent
être ignorées
elle vend à l'encontre des principes
universels inscrits dans les grandes
conventions internationales des droits
de l'homme
nous parlons d'internement des ouigours
deux camps de détention massive nous
parlons de disparition de travail forcé
de destruction du patrimoine culturel
ouigours en particulier des lieux de
culte de la surveillance de la
population est plus grand plus
globalement de tout un système répressif
mis en place dans cette région nous ne
pouvons accepter cette situation et nous
nous sommes exprimés à de nombreuses
reprises avec nos partenaires européens
nous avons marqué nos grave
préoccupation à l'égard en particulier
des camps d'internement et dont nous
avons demandé la fermeture et nous
continuerons mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs a condamné fermement ces
pratiques
je constate que les autorités chinoises
ont réagi aujourd'hui à mes propos nous
avons bien pris note de leurs réponses
mais pour autant nos positions restent
maintenues et elles sont bien connues
des autorités chinoises puisque le
présent la république lorsqu'il s'est
rendu en chine en novembre dernier on
avait fait part avec beaucoup de fermeté
nous poursuivrons notre action et il ya
une certaine manière une solution simple
qui serait que la chine permettent
l'accès des observateurs internationaux
du conseil des droits de l'homme de la
haute commissaire aux droits de l'homme
madame bachelet de se rendre sur le
place
pour faire toute la lumière sur cette
situation ce serait la bonne réponse
pour informer l'opinion publique
mondiale de la gravité des faits dans
cette région du génial tu vas les nids
mais monsieur le ministre nous prenons
acte de vos déclarations nous
désapprouvons bien sûr mais nous pensons
que ça ne suffit pas la france doit agir
de deux façons au niveau européen
en initiant des sanctions économiques
contre la chine avec ses partenaires et
au niveau international en enclenchant
le processus qui pourrait conduire la
chine demain à rendre compte de ses
actes devant une juridiction
internationale
certes nous avons des intérêts
économiques avec la chine
personne ne l'ignorent mais la
concurrence chinoise elle est déjà là
elle est impitoyable elle est sans
scrupules et la chine est une dictature
qui ne connaît qu'une règle comme toutes
les dictatures
le rapport de force alors rien ne sert
de redouter la guerre commerciale
parce que nous avons déjà la guerre mais
nous aurons aussi le déshonneur si nous
n'agissons pas monsieur le ministre
depuis longtemps depuis victor hugo ici
même dans cet hémicycle du sénat depuis
le général de gaulle à phnom penh en 66
depuis françois mitterrand en 1982 à
cancun
la france a toujours pris la défense des
peuples opprimés partout sur la terre et
aujourd'hui encore il revient au
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez
il revient au président de la république
de se montrer à la hauteur de l'histoire
à la hauteur de notre histoire nous
comprenons monsieur le ministre que les
contrôles à l'arrivée soit très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
cependant il existe un moyen de remédier
à cette difficulté exiger la
présentation d'un test négatif au départ
le problème de la déficience des
contrôles sanitaires dans les aéroports
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
nous avons alerté dès le 1er avril
l'affichage la présence des services
sanitaires ou une attestation sur
l'honneur sont notoirement insuffisants
des études épidémiologiques montrent et
démontrent que c'est de l'étranger que
de nombreux foyers de contamination
réapparaissent sur le territoire
national or rien n'a changé depuis
quatre mois il aura fallu attendre le 17
juillet
mais pour qu'un décret prévoit la mise
en quarantaine volontaire de personnes
venant de l'étranger
présentant des symptômes ou n'ayant pas
un test négatif à la gambie 19 mai ce
décret n'entrera en vigueur que dans
trois jours bien plus sa porte n est pas
nationale puisque ces mesures devraient
être prises par les préfets
dans ce même temps nombre de pays ont
soumis à l'autorisation d'accéder à
leurs sols aux seules personnes ayant
présenté dans le pays de départ un test
négatif
quelle que soit leur nationalité lâche
il vient de le faire ce qui évite la
situation ubuesque des contrôles
impossible à l'arrivée des quarantaines
invérifiable et pourquoi ne le faisons
nous pas également au moins pour les
voyageurs venant de pays à risque ou
deux pays a mis en oeuvre de telles
mesures
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est communiste de solidarité de
la santé sur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice julien je vous remercie pour
votre question qui permet peut-être de
clarifier un certain nombre de choses
tout d'abord quand vous dites que des
mesures de 14 n s'impose depuis le 17
juillet 1 la sénatrice il y a eu avant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et après
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prévoyaient les
mesures de 14 heures obligatoires madame
la sénatrice sans polémiquer en aucune
manière
j'ai de la mémoire vous aussi j'ai passé
dans cet hémicycle un certain nombre
d'heures on peut ressortir si vous
voulez les verbatim de mes différentes
interventions ainsi que les vidéos qui
sont publiés sur le site de public sénat
sur lesquels vous prendrez connaissance
un certain nombre de débats que nous
avons pu avoir sur le texte qui porte
est sorti l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
d'un certain nombre de tentatives pour
lesquelles je n'ai pas rencontré un
franc succès qui visait à ne pas
totalement nous désarmer bien que nous
soyons sortis l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour mettre en place encore en attente
de mesures de protection des personnes
en france
vous vous en souvenez bien parmi ces
mesures qui ne sont plus possibles hors
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire il y en a
une qui consisterait à imposer un
citoyen français en france de faire un
test pcr
on peut le demander c'est ce que nous
faisons madame la sénatrice pour toutes
les personnes qui viennent des pays dans
lesquels le virus circule nous leur
demandons instamment de présenter les
résultats d'un test négatif réalisés
dans les 72 heures précédant leur départ
si les personnes n'ont pas réalisé ce
tête
si les personnes n'ont pas réalisé le
test que nous leur demandons pourtant
bien mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
de réaliser dans les 72 heures avant
qu'il quitte le pays dont ils sont
originaires
et qu'ils arrivent en france nous leur
donnons deux possibilités ou produire
les résultats d'un test négatif réalisés
dans les 48 heures et pour faciliter la
vie des voyageurs nous avons mis en
place nous sommes l'un des seuls pays à
l'avoir fait des plateformes de tests
pcr au sein même des aéroports capable
d'ores et déjà de faire 2000 tests par
jour gratuit pris en charge et remboursé
par la sécurité sociale
sans quoi nous leur demandons de
respecter madame la sénatrice mme une
quatorzaine à domicile et nous les
accompagnons dans la réalisation de
cette 14ème j'entends votre question les
faits sont têtus benhamza messieurs les
sénateurs il ya d'ailleurs des documents
qui en attestent
et qui sont envoyées à tous les
voyageurs en instant arrivée sur notre
territoire national je ne dis pas je ne
dis pas que la solution est parfaite
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mais
que n'avez vous pas que ne vais vous
pensé à cela au moment où nous avaient
désarmé dans la loi et ce que nous avons
souhaité sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire aux abus lien
je ne doute pas monsieur le ministre
votre volonté mais on ne peut que
constater que ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionne pas
la parole des collègues andré gattolin
pour le groupe de la république en
marche
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse
s'il vous plaît à monsieur à madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
madame la ministre il ya un an et demi
'l'annonce d'un projet de loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour la
recherche avec quelque chose d'assez
visionnaire puisque jamais une telle loi
n'avait été instauré dans ce domaine
d'où d'ailleurs
non mais vous avez autre chose à dire là
c'est moi qui préside monsieur gâteau
doit continuer à merci monsieur le
président aujourd'hui dans le contexte
de crise économique et sanitaire que
nous traversons est laid mais chaque
collègue tout simplement salutaire est
indispensable cette crise a en effet
souligné combien la recherche est un
élément indissociable à la souveraineté
nationale
combien il est nécessaire de doter la
recherche de moyens budgétaires au long
cours tant elle a besoin de constance et
de visibilité en terme d'engagement
financier en ce sens l'investissement de
25 milliards d'euros sur dix ans que
père et voilà l ppr va dans le bon sens
tout comme l'augmentation significative
des dotations de l' agence nationale de
la recherche
permettez-moi néanmoins madame la
ministre attirer votre attention sur les
chercheurs eux-mêmes qui sont les
piliers de la recherche dans notre pays
nombre d'entre eux continuent à quitter
la france pour d'autres pays pour ne pas
citer notamment les états unis
il ne la quitte pas par vénalité non ils
la quittent parce qu'ailleurs les
budgets alloués à la recherche
permettent tout simplement de faire et
de bien faire leur métier
aussi madame la ministre ma question est
simple
avec ce texte qu'est ce qui changera
concrètement pour les chercheurs en
termes de conditions de travail et avez
vous des éléments chiffrés et des
engagements précis à nous transmettre à
ce sujet je vous remercie pour vos
réponses apparu et a révélé de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
l'innovation par abidal vous avez la
parole
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices monsieur
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gâteau là
vous l'avez rappelé est le plus grand
investissement qu'un gouvernement est
fait sur la recherche depuis l'après
guerre
et évidemment ce sera très important
pour moi que nous puissions échanger
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois
à propos de ce projet de loi qu'est ce
que ce projet de loi prévoit d'ailleurs
il prévoit de reconnaître l'engagement
le travail
l'ensemble des missions assurées par les
chercheurs par les
enseignants-chercheurs au service de la
production de la connaissance et au
service de notre société au sens le plus
large puisque vous le savez ce sont ses
connaissances qui nous celle d'hier
qu'ils nous ont permis d'affronter des
crises d'aujourd'hui et celles qui vont
être produites à partir d'aujourd'hui
qui nous permettra je n'en doute pas
d'affronter les crises de demain alors
vous demander qu'est ce qui va changer
concrètement tout d'abord une
simplification qui vient du terrain
plusieurs mois depuis plusieurs mois
nous travaillons avec l'ensemble des
laboratoires avec l'ensemble des
chercheurs des enseignants chercheurs
pour voir qu'est ce qui très
concrètement les empêche d'exercer leur
métier ils ont besoin de temps et c'est
pourquoi il y aura des créations
d'emploi supplémentaires pour
accompagner les chercheurs et les
enseignants chercheurs dans tous les
métiers de la recherche ils ont besoin
de reconnaissance
c'est pourquoi il y aura une
revalorisation sans précédent pour
l'ensemble des métiers de la recherche
ils ont besoin de moyens c'est pourquoi
nous prévoyons non seulement de porter
le budget de l'agencé nationale de la
recherche à un milliard d'euros
mais que s'ajoute aussi 450 millions
d'euros qui viendront alimenter la
recherche de base au travers de l'
agence nationale de la recherche
mais pas pour autant sur des projets
ciblés simplement parce que lorsqu'une
équipe gagne dans un laboratoire c'est
l'ensemble du laboratoire qui gagne
c'est l'ensemble des autres équipes qui
ont aidé le chercheur dans son anr c'est
une grande joie pour la recherche et je
serai très fier de la porter devant vous
je remercie
jusque là oui très rapidement merci
madame la ministre je crois que un point
quand même important dans le monde de la
recherche vers la france ne se classe
pas dans les meilleures positions dans
le domaine des sciences sociales et
humaines et il y aura un effort en
particulier en termes de compétition
internationale à faire puisqu'on le voit
nous échouons malheureusement très
souvent dans les contrats et des appels
d'offres qui sont lancés au niveau
repères je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
catherine procaccia pour le groupe des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ma question
concerne aussi le retard que prend la
france dans le contrôle aux frontières
et dans les aéroports
et si ma question ressemble à celle de
madame vullien c'est parce que c'est une
préoccupation des parlementaires et des
français il n'y a quasiment aucun
contrôle qu'ovide autre que les relevés
de température qui sont mis en place
place par les exploitants et que l'état
n'a pas rendu obligatoire il y a surtout
plusieurs heures d'attentes aux arrivées
dans les aéroports qui mélange les
voyageurs de plusieurs avions sans
respect des gestes barrières sans
distinction entre français et étrangers
et surtout sans aucun suivi
et quoi que vous nous ayez répondu
monsieur le ministre
aucun certificat médical ni résultats de
tests négligé pour l'instant quelle que
soit la zone d'où arrivent les voyageurs
et même si les autorités locales
décident de mesures de confinement comme
par exemple à barcelone et combes de
l'unité l'inutilité cette attestation
sur l'honneur assurant que l'on n'a pas
le coc vide que personne ne réclame et
alors qu'une grande partie des malades
sont asymptomatiques
ce constat alarmant est dénoncée par
tous et particulièrement par les
médecins hospitaliers qui voit arriver
de plus en plus de binationaux et
d'étrangers contaminée qui n'ont eu
aucun suivi depuis leur atterrissage une
nouvelle fois la france prend du retard
une nouvelle fois elle est incapable de
mettre en place autrement que sur le
papier ce que presque tous nos voisins
font des contrôles aux frontières
systématique pas seulement incitatif et
au bon vouloir du passager
et ne parlons pas des 2000 tests pcr
journalier annoncée alors que ce sont
près de 20 mille voyageurs qui arrivent
chaque jour de ces zones rouges
ma question est simple allez vous mettre
en place des contrôles obligatoires est
réel et éviter que nous a hero port ne
deviennent des passoires aco vide on
vous répondra par l'automobiliste de
solidarité et de la santé dix secondes
madame la sénatrice pro cassia il me
faudrait plus de deux minutes pour
répondre factuellement à la question que
vous vous avez posées ne serait ce que
pour présenter les chiffres quand vous
dites la dangerosité vient de l'étranger
j'ai demandé figurez-vous aux hôpitaux
parisiens de m'indiquer combien de
malades originaires de l'étranger et est
actuellement hospitalisé dans les
réanimations si on exclut les repères
les rapatriements sanitaires de français
que nous avons donc rapatrié dans nos
hôpitaux parce qu'ils étaient gravement
malades à l'étranger
nous parlons sur l'ensemble des hôpitaux
parisiens et depuis la date du 15 juin
de cinq malades
je ne dis pas que ça ne compte pas
madame la sénatrice je dis juste que
quand vous dites que le je vous dis que
lorsque vous dites que la dangerosité
bien l'étranger les chiffres encore une
fois sont têtus quand vous dites que
tous nos voisins ont mis en place des
mesures draconiennes drastique
obligatoires madame la sénatrice je vous
demande de venir me voir après la séance
et nous appelons nous appellerons
ensemble comme je lé fais l'ensemble des
ministres de la santé des pays du
conseil européen et vous constaterez
avec moi que à part la france il n'y a
pas encore véritablement d'autres pays
européens qui ont mis en place des
contrôles pcr disponibles jusque dans
les aérogares des aéroports maintenant
madame la sénatrice parlons parlant
sérieusement 2,2 secondes pour tester
mille personnes dans un aéroport
il faut une équipe de 40 personnes pour
tester 35000 personnes dans un aéroport
c'est le nombre de passagers qui est
attendu à par exemple à roissy en
période pré estivale
ouvrez le compte et avec moins il faut
1200 nous pouvons le faire nous pouvons
demander à 1200 personnes d'être en
permanence à l'aéroport de mettre en
place un tri est demandé à tous les
passagers de passer plusieurs heures
dans la tente des aérogares nous pouvons
effectivement envisagée pour sa madame
la sénatrice
encore une fois il faudrait une
disposition législative que nous n'avons
plus parce qu'elle a été
désamorcé dans le débat parlementaire et
notamment je le redis parce qu'il faut
assumer dame madame g messieurs les
sénateurs dans le cadre du débat
sénatorial par la majorité sénatoriale
maintenant madame la sénatrice pour tous
les ressortissants tous les
ressortissants qui ne sont pas bi
nationaux et qui viennent de pays qui
sont classées rouge c'est-à-dire dans
lesquels le virus circule plus qu'en
france ils ne peuvent pas rentrer et
nous sommes en train de parler de
ressenti sur binationaux des français
qui sont dans des pays où le virus
circule beaucoup et qui reviennent en
france à qui je le confirme
nous demandons de réaliser sur place un
test dans les 72 heures et si le test
n'est pas disponible dans les pays parce
que ça peut arriver notamment dans les
pays rouges
nous mettons en place des tests à
l'aéroport et nous les accompagnons dans
une 14/n le cas échéant jusqu'à ce
qu'ils puissent bénéficier d'un test
croyez moi nous sommes déterminés sur ce
sujet nous n'avons certainement pas
envie de permettre au virus de circuler
d'où qu'il vienne que ce soit de
l'international ou de l'étranger
accompagnez nous dans les dispositifs
législatifs accompagnez-nous et soyez
fiers à peu de ce que nous sommes
capables de mettre en oeuvre pour
protéger les français
[Applaudissements]
l'impro cassia vous avez quelques
secondes
merci vous dites monsieur le ministre
qu'il ya très peu originaires de
l'étranger
j'ai bien dit qu'il y avait des
binationaux qui était dans les hôpitaux
je ne les ai pas inventés c'est dans
toute la presse et dans tous les
journaux
et puis quand on est temps de monsieur
le premier ministre parle de fermer la
frontière avec l'espagne
est-ce qu'il faut attendre qu'un jour un
décret pour faire en sorte que l'on
contrôle les gens qui arrivent de
barcelone ce n'est pas fait et est ce
qu'on va faire comme la dernière fois
avec l'italie pholien avait fermé les
frontières et on a continué à les
accueillir sans aucun contrôle
on est inquiets monsieur le ministre
merci la parole et la van hamme la
présidente hélène conway mouret pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous connaissez parfaitement
l'enseignement supérieur vous en est
issu vous ne pouvez ignorer ces
problèmes
vous les avez vécu alors il est
difficile de comprendre pourquoi dès
votre arrivée à la tête de ce grand
ministère qui préparent l'avenir de nos
jeunes mais également de notre pays
vous n'avez pas lancer immédiatement un
grand plan de relance global sur le
quinquennat afin de rattraper les sous
investissements structurels dont
souffrent nos universités les
investissements étaient insuffisants
depuis 20 ans c'est un fait mais
aujourd'hui c'est le problème majeur
il faudrait ouvrir une nouvelle faculté
tous les ans pour accueillir les plus de
trente mille étudiants supplémentaires
la dotation par étudiant ne cesse de
baisser pour être aujourd'hui au niveau
de 2008
ce problème financier pèse également sur
l'emploi avec une baisse très nette des
recrutements due à la précarisation de
l'emploi des enseignants chercheurs à
laquelle vous commencez enfin de
répondre par la lpp airs que vous avez
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres cependant 99% des 25 milliards
annoncés ne seront disponibles qu'après
de plus ces crédits qui repose sur des
appels à projets ne sont pas garanties
les universités ont besoin de moyens
maintenant et ne peuvent attendre le
prochain quinquennat madame la ministre
nous venons d'examiner trois plfr dans
lesquelles vous aviez l'occasion de
garantir des crédits afin de financer
vos annonces et pourtant vous attendez
deux jours après la fin des débats pour
annoncer l'ouverture de dix mille places
supplémentaires que vous financez commet
aucune aide non plus pour la création
pendant l'été d'un enseignement à
distance qui retient pourtant les
investissements alors que vous avez
refusé ici comme à l'assemblée nationale
tous les amendements qui tendait à
soutenir les doctorants et les boursiers
pour la rentrée prochaine
rassurez-nous adam la ministre en nous
disant que vous avez réservé tous vos
efforts pour le plf à venir
la parole et kavala de la milice
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et l'innovation en abidal la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mais les sénatrices nationale affirme m
la présidence de la crise ont commémoré
jeu je comprends le sens de votre
question je pense que nous partageons
l'idée qu'effectivement il est temps de
réinvestir massivement dans la recherche
dans notre pays
mais je voudrais peut-être apporter des
précisions sur ce que vous venez sur ce
que vous venez de dire vous dit rien
n'est prévu pour que l'on prévoit d
enseignement à distance à la rentrée
c'est 30 millions d'euros mêmes qui sont
à la disposition des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur pour préparer
cette rentrée universitaire avec des
formations à distance vous dites que le
financement des doctorants n'est pas
assurée nous avons prolongé d'une année
la possibilité d'avoir des contrats
doctoraux financer et c'est la même
chose pour les à terre et pour un
certain nombre de post doctorants vous
dites que nous devrions construire une
université par an vous le savez comme
moi la construction d'une université ça
se prévoit c'est dans les années 2000
que l'on savait que la courbe
démographique atteindra son pic en 2018
je suis arrivé ce gouvernement est
arrivé en 2017 ça nous était très
compliqué de construire une université
parents et surtout de rattraper le
retard
alors oui le plan étudiants a permis de
réinjecter un milliard d'euros pour
l'accueil spécifique des étudiants en
premier cycle
oui aujourd'hui ce sont 25 milliards
d'euros qui vont être consacrés et
réinvestit à la rochelle pour la
recherche c'est vous donner un ordre de
grandeur 50 millions d'euros sur le
programme recherche 172 entre 2012 et
ses 201 millions dès l'année prochaine
c'est 559 millions l'année suivante ça
veut dire qu'en deux ans nous aurons
fait seize fois plus qu entre 2012 et
oui on pourrait toujours espérer plus
mais parfois le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien
je préfère que nous commencions à
investir sincèrement et ray
man dans l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche vous remercie même quand on
est bourré madame la présidente
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que nous sommes habitués à
une communication avec des superlatifs
mais aujourd'hui je crois que nous avons
besoin d'une vision globale pour pour
les universités et surtout il ya une
grande inquiétude pour la rentrée
prochaine
vous n'êtes pas sans le savoir est ce
que nous attendons et sachez que le
sénat sera au rendez-vous prochain en
tout cas pour voter des crédits si cela
était avancée pour votre ministère nous
l'avons été avec les repas à 1 euro mais
nous avons besoin de soutenir nos
universités leur personnel et les
étudiants
[Musique]